Irene Palmer was born on March 2nd 1930
in Bridgeport Connecticut as we can see
right here on her passport Irene's mom
was deeply religious claiming that God
spoke to her directly as a girl Irene
had a series of Visions just like her
mother but her father never believed any
of this he thought his wife was crazy
and had her committed to a psychiatric
hospital forcing a tearful goodbye I
will always be right here that was the
last she ever saw of her mom but her
Visions continued which created issues
with her father after each Vision Irene
would be left with the same thought in
her head Mary points the way word of her
Visions eventually reached the Catholic
church and they sent a bishop to meet
with the family and convince her father
not to have her committed as well the
script for the nun offers a little more
insight scripts are not usually
considered Canon but this is one of
those cases where it's relatively
non-contradictory and even fits pretty
well with the nun too so I do want to
talk about it briefly Irene was
investigated by the church to see if she
had potentially been possessed but it
was ultimately decided that she was pure
the bishop suggested that she dedicate
her life to the Lord and when she did so
her vision stopped so she planned to
become a nun when she reached the proper
age and this process was sped up when
Irene was sent away to live in Europe by
her father I was different sending me
away was easier than trying to
understand who I was so she was born in
Bridgeport Connecticut has psychic
visions and became connected to the
Catholic church if you follow the
conjuring franchise this should all
sound similar to another character the
Paranormal Investigator SL basically
superhero Lorraine Warren so what is the
deal here what is the true relationship
between these two characters to answer
that question and to hear my full
analysis of Sister Irene stick around to
the end of this
[Music]
video Welcome to Horror history yes I
have conjured up another one from The
Conjuring universe as the highest
grossing horror franchise of all time
The Conjuring films have done a great
job of incorporating familiar elements
to keep people interested in the
spin-offs the Annabelle doll was
introduced in the first movie and became
the centerpiece of several films of her
own but for the non spin-off series the
antagonist was not the only familiar
element in April 2017 it was announced
that taisa far GA had been cast to play
the lead role taisa is the sister of
Vera Farmiga who plays Lorraine Warren
in the mainline Conjuring film so fans
immediately began speculating that she
could be related to lorine or possibly
even a younger version of her now last
time I said the word titular in a video
I pronounce it wrong I said titular and
everybody just eviscerated me in the
comments and I just wanted to defend
myself because the word refers to the
title of a work so in my mind it makes
sense that it would be titular like
title but I admit I was wrong I think
next time I'll just play it safe and say
e pony m reason I bring this up is this
Variety article claims that the younger
Farmiga sister is playing the titular
role in the nun and I think that's kind
of arguable yes she does play a nun or
at least she becomes a nun but when I
hear the title the nun I'm not thinking
about her I'm thinking about the nun
demon Valic I don't think anyone would
go to see a nun movie if Valic was not
in it but they would probably be just
fine if they did one without Sister
Irene but that being said I would prefer
to see more of this character not less
it would be fun to see her go up against
another villain in a different spin-off
series at some point because her
backstory is mostly left is a mystery
other than a few Clues here and there so
to begin unraveling them let's take it
back to the unexpected guest who changed
the course of her
life as an adult Sister Irene works at
St Vincent Hospital in London England
she still plans on becoming a nun but
hasn't taken her vows yet making her a
noviciate something that Everyone likes
to point out constantly you still
haven't taken your temporary vows you
haven't taken your vows yet you haven't
taken your vow it now you know how I
feel every time someone asks me to make
a nto video I'm literally doing it
different cultures handle it differently
but they're basically three steps to
becoming a nun first there's discernment
that's where you're considered a sister
or a noviciate but not yet a nun once a
sister takes her temporary vows she
becomes a nun and this kind of allows
her to test the lifestyle and if she's
successful she may make her Perpetual
vow signifying lifelong commitment in
1952 she's a natural history teacher for
a group of kids who are maybe in fourth
grade I have survived many terrifying
encounters but nothing could have ever
prepared me for this my only hope now
was that the Beast could not smell me
but then the wind
changed
and this may just be a fictional story
that she's telling to these kids to
entertain them but it could be a
personal story about her experiences
growing up with Supernatural Visions
it's possible that she's already taken
on an entity in her past if she grew up
alongside Lorraine Warren then I would
say it's very likely since we know rain
had Visions from a young age as well you
know when I was about your age um I was
visiting my mom at a hospital and I saw
an angel standing next to a little boy's
bed it was just gently touching his
cheek and then stopped by the way if
Irene and Lorraine grew up together
which they most likely did given that
Lorraine was born in 1927 and Irene was
born in 1930 then they're most likely
cousins we know that they aren't sisters
because Line's mom is still around in
old age but Irene's is not her
dedication to religion made her believe
that anything could be a sign for from
God such as her brushing red paintt onto
this girl's nose we'll come back to that
she's visited by a representative of the
Vatican which is basically like the HQ
of the Catholic Church his name is
Father Burke and she learns that she's
been assigned to assist him on an
investigation of an unusual phenomenon
in beertown Romania due to her
familiarity with the territory Romania
I'd never been in that part of the World
perhaps she's been chosen not because
she is geographically familiar but
rather because she's familiar with the
territory of Supernatural encounters
maybe even involving evil entities this
begs the question why would they choose
her over Lorraine after all this was the
same year Lorraine founded the New
England society for psychic research at
least in real life it seems Irene was
chosen because of the nature of the
mission father Burke was to bring her to
The Abbey of St Carta to determine if
the grounds were still holy since it is
a cloistered Convent and your access
will be limited this basically means
that they're giving him a guide because
the church is cut off from the outside
world given that she's a nun in training
she would be allowed to explore the
inside more than a normal civilian like
Lorraine but after arriving in Romania
things would prove more difficult than
anticipated their first stop in Romania
is to visit Maurice theel commonly known
as Frenchie he's immediately flirting
with her until learning that she's a
prospective nun however she still charms
him enough to convince him to take them
up to The Abbey with all due respect
father
please
Frenchie
that was not that difficult don't you
have anything better to do than simp
once reaching the edge of the ground
their horse refuses to continue and they
have to go by foot this is just like the
dog in The Conjuring who refused to
enter the house haunted by the witch
baath Sheba they learned that the locals
spit on the ground whenever the topic of
the Abby is brought up and the cross is
lining the perimeter maybe keeping the
evil locked in they visit the ice house
to check on the body of the nun who
killed herself sister Victoria and she's
strangely been moved into an upright
position Burke discovers a key clenched
in her hands and they decide to give her
a proper for burial outside Sister Irene
begins to notice a number of strange
things the blood at the sight of
Victoria's death is still fresh and upon
entering the Abbey she senses something
behind her without looking this appears
to be the Reverend mother or essentially
the head nun but what they don't know is
that this is actually valik the defiler
an ancient demon who was responsible for
the evil plaguing The Abbey quick Horror
history lesson for those who haven't
seen my Valic episode this creature
escaped from hell and killed off each of
the nuns in the Abbey their Spirits
continue to inhabit the place as ghosts
but the Reverend mother's ghost is under
Val's control much like how Bill Wilkins
ghost was controlled in The Conjuring
too they're asked to come back in the
morning since the sisters take a vow of
silence after Sunset I bet my neighbors
wish I would take a vow of silence after
Sunset but hey it's the best time to
record videos but Sister Irene and
father Burke nearly don't make it to
Sunrise Burke gets trapped in a Coffin
by Valic and Irene is woken up by a
breeze in the middle of her sleep if her
Visions are believed to be messages sent
to her by God I don't think it's crazy
to assume that this was God waking her
up so that she could save her comrade
and stand a chance to defeat Valic later
on she comes upon some kind of midnight
ritual in a chapel where Valic appears
to her as a shadow but after she
realizes the ritual was all an
apparition and the Demonic entity makes
itself known in a bold
way the fact that Sister Irene sees
valik in its non form in the mirror has
to be symbolic of the choice that lies
ahead of her she's considering becoming
a nun herself but struggles to make the
commitments to take her vows it's almost
as if Valic in the mirror represents her
fears about her potential future a theme
that would come up throughout her story
she's also not the only one to encounter
Valic in this way this is another
connection Sister Irene shares with
Lorraine also in the nearby town they
have a tradition to cover their mirrors
whenever someone dies so that the SE
doesn't see their reflection this is
likely why valik destroyed the mirror so
that Sister Irene can never find out
that all of the nuns are already dead
after fleeing the chapel she hears a
bell ringing and instantly knows that
father Burke is in trouble the grave
sites around the perimeter contain what
are known as safety coffin the Bell
System was developed in 1892 with
strings connecting the occupants head
hands and feet feet to a bell on the
outside this way these Cemetery Watchmen
would be alerted if they accidentally
Buried one alive if you're wondering if
this is where the phrase Saved by the
Bell comes from it's not according to
this article from Ripley's Believe it or
not but apparently the phrase doesn't
come from school either it comes from
boxing and it's someone who shares a
name with the main character from a
cultural Touchstone sitcom called Save
By the Bell you would think I would know
that anyway Sister Irene had learned
about the safety coffins earlier that
day and somehow knew that the father was
in trouble when she heard one ringing as
she got close Valic chimed all of the
Bell in order to confuse her and we see
her close her eyes and envision which
distress call is the real
deal the next day he sends Irene away
with the key acquired from Sister
Victoria's cold dead fingers I bet he
tells that story like seriously whenever
he gets the chance and then I pride the
key from her cold dead
hands waiter one more round please
Sister Irene finds the main sanctuary
and comes across sister Anana who
informs her that the nuns are taking
pray shifts to maintain a constant state
of prayer sister Victoria's death was a
terrible tragedy for the
convent but we still feel her
presence she was the most devoted out of
any of us has anyone else noticed that
we are literally getting shamal longed
right now they don't know they're dead
personally I'm never one to complain
about getting shamal longed or Weezer or
rick rolled or even Josh Hutcherson
whistle
edited they also discuss an impostor nun
which sister Anana describes as
something Unholy perhaps the evil
reemerging after being sealed for so
many years another sister sister Abigail
instructs sister Anana to resume her
prayers and tells Irene that she should
not be here since she's not taking her
vows yet we get it however she's
told that she has to stay the night
because the gates have once again closed
until morning my theory about the
mirrors being connected to Irene's fear
of becoming a nun is supported here
because the room that she stays in
contains a mirror and she receives
another Vision in her dream where Mary
points the way Echoes through her head
and she envisions Valic the suicide of
sister Victoria and a girl covered in
blood when she awakens a door opens and
she's beckoned to explore by a spectral
voice leading to the discovery of an
underground passage marked by the words
Phi Deo Latin for God ends here it opens
to reveal the bane of all things holy
valent she finds herself suddenly in a
windstorm as she tries to escape but the
evil nun just grins menacingly at her it
comes to a halt as she's slammed into
the door but then this
happens what little light there is in
the corridor is smothered away and she's
pulled into a hiding spot by Sister
Anana when the threat passes she's
instructed to get her things and meet in
the chapel so they can pray their way
through the night but after arriving
there Sister Irene makes a gruesome
[Music]
Discovery in the main sanctuary Irene
finds a nun praying fervently next to a
body under a sheet which turns out to be
sister oana a whole flock of nuns storms
in I'm pretty sure I established in a
previous video at some point that a
group of nuns traveling together like
this should be referred to as a flock
and I'm sticking with it they lock the
place up and sister Ruth urges Irene to
pray with them and whatever happens
whatever you may see or hear keep your
eyes forward and don't stop praying
Sister Irene hyperventilates but
complies suddenly a blast arates all of
the other nuns away from her and she
does exactly what sister Ruth told her
not to do she diverts her eyes and her
prayer is interrupted this whole scene
is another test of her commitment to
religion on her journey to becoming a
nun by looking away she's distracted Ed
by outside elements but then she
refocuses her attention and continues
her prayer her Garb is then ripped open
from behind but this is not Frenchie
choosing an inopportune time to make his
move it is instead an invisible force
that scratches a pentagram into her back
this is another test of her dedication
she must tune out the pain and continue
her prayer it's like when you're trying
to get work done but then you see the
notification that C's world just
uploaded and you have to resist the
temptation to watch the video except in
that scenario the correct answer is to
watch the video or at least put it on in
the background but my point is that her
restraint was being tested she only
stops when she hears father Burke and
Frenchie trying to get in and one of the
other nuns gives her a nod of approval
after letting them in she lets them know
that they've all been praying to hold
back the evil but when she turns back
all of the others are gone and this is
what makes her realize that the nuns
that she's been seeing up until this
point were just part of her Visions or
rather spirits of the deceased nuns that
once inhabited the ABY in other words
there was nobody left when they arrived
the place is filled with ghosts and
apparently reanimated
Corpses
he instructs her to get some holy water
from his bag and throw it on the evil
none and I love in all these movies
whenever they try to make these priests
like these badass action heroes and they
just have their satchels packed with
holy water so they can whip it out like
a gun and it works it works every time
he dowes across in holy water and uses
it to drive the Demonic Force out of the
nun's body which Goes Up in Flames when
the an Deacon no longer endure the
Divinity bearing down on it Frenchie is
about ready to GTFO but Sister Irene
bravely insists that they cannot leave
without first sealing the gateway to
contain the evil she she's come a long
way At first she had no idea what her
purpose was on this Mission but now
she's the one leading the charge into
the underground passages to search for
the blood of Christ that will supposedly
send the Crooked noosed conventual back
to where it came from and having found
her purpose she's ready to make a
commitment that she wasn't sure about
before I'd like to take my vows she does
this because she's discovered that her
Visions are a miracle of God either that
or she's just sick of everybody asking
her about it it's kind of an elf for
Frenchie that that sister is a noble act
it's a shame but oh French
you'll find someone briefly then you'll
die imagine if you were crushing on a
girl and then she became a nun and swore
herself to celibacy that's kind of like
I don't know I think I'd be kind of
salty father Burke helps her make what I
believe are her temporary vows and she's
te- posing face down on the ground so
that's kind of funny after officially
becoming a nun she feels she's ready to
face down the demon posing as a nun no
longer willing to be taunted by the form
that she felt mocked by in the corridors
Under The Abbey a beam of light shines
down on the finger of this Virgin Mary
statue connecting to the phrase
associated with her her Visions since
childhood Mary points the way and
further making her believe that her
Visions came from God they follow the
beam to a secret keyhole in the wall and
unlock it using the key recovered from
Sister Victoria to find the glass orb
containing the blood of Christ and
father Burke tells her that only a true
bride of Christ can wield it so I guess
it's a good thing she did her vows with
the Ultimate Weapon in hand they proceed
past the Cellar Door for the first time
into the area where evil Reigns Supreme
they split up you know the thing you're
definitely supposed to do in a horror
movie and Irene is stalked by a faceless
nun as she hears the whis Whispers of
the spirits of the nuns who had assisted
her but before she can do anything she's
choke slammed by Valic and runs to a
seemingly unused storage room for safety
once again there's a mirror and for the
third time now it would be connected to
Valic she's encircled by five candles
which light themselves and she realizes
that she's standing in a pentagram but
as she runs for the exit she's stopped
in her tracks by an army of robed
figures who abduct her and bag her head
forcing her to join their ranks Frenchie
eventually finds her but when he
uncovers her head she's been possessed
by valet and she arates him into a
pillar which he's pinned against this is
the next logical step in the mirror
metaphor Val had used mirrors to make
Irene fear her future as a nun and now
that she's realized that life by
becoming one Valic would literally
possess her it's bringing those fears to
fruition the possessed Irene hurls
targeted insults about Frenchie being
the village idiot it's a Trope that
we've seen a lot in the exorcism genre
going back to the Exorcist however he's
able to use the vial hanging from her
neck to smear the blood of Christ on her
face calling back to the beginning of
the adventure when she smeared the paint
on the girl's nose this has an immediate
and powerful effect exercising the demon
from her body and it's honestly just
nice to see an exorcism scene in this
franchise that doesn't involve throwing
up that black substance she's knocked
aside as Valic deviously grabs Frenchie
by the throat and flashes a disgusting
smile in her Direction she tries to bum
rush the evil entity but she's arated
completely out of the room into a pool
of water that's forming by flooding from
overhead it's possible that this moment
is supposed to represent a symbolic
baptism a baptism is a Christian
practice of submerging a person in water
to cleanse or purify them as an
initiation to joining the religion this
is more of a symbolic baptism than a
literal one being baptized is a
requirement for being a Catholic nun so
it's likely that Sister Irene already
went through the baptism ceremony when
she was young but now that she's taken
her vows and joined The Sisterhood of
nuns she's starting a new chapter in her
life on the website TV Tropes a symbolic
baptism is defined as a sign of
character development where swimming or
watery immersion marks a major turning
point in the character's life most
commonly it marks the point where the
character begins to let go of the past
or is initiated into a new phase of
their life so this fits Sister Irene
pretty well she loses grasp of the Holy
Grail but when she goes to reach for it
she notices valac rising up from below
the
surface Bic attacks and holds down
Sister Irene under the water even father
Burke's prayers do little to slow it
down however he does provide just enough
of a distraction for Irene to bring the
Grail to her mouth under the surface
with that Valic believes that it's one
and lifts her up to eye level but
realized IES the contents of the glass
case have been removed and Irene
outsmarts her hellish counterpart with
where she's hidden the
goods for years the people in town have
spit on the ground after any mention of
the evil as ancient Superstition and now
Irene is using the same tactic to
hopefully finish it off for good and
this has a devastating effect as valik
appears to be sucked down into a Vortex
and back where it came from before
leaving she gives a proper blessing to
the nuns of St Carta thought this girl
wasn't holy anymore it is now and before
leaving Romania she sees off Frenchie at
the train station and learns that he's
planning on going to Hungary then
traveling the world at some point after
this she must have gone back to the
Vatican with Father Burke and met
Cardinal Conroy who was obviously
impressed Enough by her work to call
upon her again in the future the story
of what happened in Romania kind of
becomes an urban legend among the other
sisters and nuns what happened to the
nun well no one really knows they say
the experience was too much for her some
say that she went mad it seems like it
would be difficult for gossip to spread
considering that cloistered nuns
generally do not travel however other
nuns and sisters do apparently travel a
lot primarily for missionary work where
they try to recruit people in other
countries to their religion they would
not be the only ones bothering people
from other countries after lying dormant
inside of Frenchie for 4 years valik
would reemerge in 1955 and 1956 and take
four victims across Europe one of which
was a priest named father no who was
ulated at his church in terascon France
because of course the French priest
would be named after wine that night
Irene wakes up in the middle of the
night in a manner very similar to when
the breeze woke her up at St carda right
down to the way that the curtains blow
in the breeze given my earlier analysis
I would interpret this as a Divine call
to action and in fact this is another
dream a vision of Maurice possessed by
Valic and asking to be saved the next
day she's visited by Cardinal Conroy she
doesn't look thrilled to see him which
is kind of understandable considering
this dude only shows up to deliver bad
news there has been an incident see I
told you he doesn't even make any small
talk first I'm the exact same way she's
given the lowdown in the four gruesome
deaths moving west across Europe which
they suspect to be the work of the demon
that she thought she had sealed away
four years prior with the help of Father
Burke speaking of whom father Burke is
dead see this guy never has any good
news she doesn't want to go but they
basically Strongarm her luckily her
friend sister Deborah tags along to look
after her so she's not completely solo
as she begins her search at the site of
the last known incident terascon France
like The Abbey in Romania there's a
belief that this church is Cur first
following Val's appearance as she looks
around the place she's able to see
visions of the past falling Ash the
burnt up husk of Father nor Reay and the
boy who inherited his Rosary they're
taken to see father Noir re's room and
they come across a picture of St Lucy
patron saint of the blind like much of
the lore in the contraverse St Lucy is
based on a real person a saint from
Italy in the 200s who devoted herself to
Christianity there are a number of myths
and stories about the cause of her
blindness some versions say that she
gouged out her own eyes when a potential
lover became infatuated with them in
order to prove prove her dedication to
religion and virginity another take on
the matter tells of how she was captured
by the Roman Emperor Diocesan and her
eyes were gouged out prior to her
execution that seems to be closer to the
version of the tale that appears in the
controverse she was murdered by pagans
they lit her on fire but she wouldn't
burn before killing her they gouged out
her eyes very metal iene learns that
Frenchie had worked at this very church
as a handyman until father nor was
killed and comes to the realization
pretty quickly that he must have been
the vessel that smuggled Valic out of
the Abbey and the reason that these
tragedy are seemingly spreading across
the continent while checking in at the
hotel terascon Irene 6 sense is on high
alert and she's LED out into the street
where she sees the alter boy jacqu among
a group of kids playing European
football jacqu was the one whose father
was killed by valent in pursuit of
answers she finds herself at a news
stand where the Wind Blows the pages of
each magazine open to the right page to
collectively form The Haunting image of
valik right next to this picture of
harambe when she gets close to it Valic
appears in a Flash and grabs her throat
and in this instant she receives a
vision of a burning ritual in a forest
where a man in a Red Cloak stabs a nun
in the face as she holds some kind of
artifact he stabs her twice then we see
a Divine Light coming from her eyes
leading me to believe that this is a
representation of St Lucy patron saint
of the blind Irene passes out in the
streets not waking up until the next
morning I'm not sure if the doctor was
using a figure of speech or if Irene's
survival from this incident was not
guaranteed there she is back from the
dead I kind of wish we could see what
happened in between it seems like she
was out for like 8 hours at least was
the doctor just prodding her and Shining
lights in her eyes all night until she
woke up and then he just leaves without
getting paid are we sure this dude is a
real doctor what happened last night nah
that's what she should be asking you
anyway Irene concludes that Valic is
using Frenchie to get at this Relic that
she saw in her vision while she was
unconscious jacqu visited sister Deborah
and dropped off his father's Rosary
which is basically this necklace with a
cross which is often seen being used to
fend off demons and it also contains
this symbol the symbol it seems so
familiar but but I can't place it I'll
give her the benefit of the doubt and
just assume that she's still a little
foggy since she just woke up but it's
clearly the symbol from the artifact in
her vision which doesn't seem like it
was that long ago the symbol also
matches a piece of jewelry seen in the
crime scene photos of the other Valic
victims provided by Cardinal bad news
conr they hurry to P dup pop the
Catholic archives to try to learn what
they can about the symbol but they would
also receive a tip that would have
Rippling
[Music]
ramifications the librarian at the
Catholic archives is able to identify
the symbol they brought in as the family
crest of St Lucy the archist thinks that
each of the Demon's victims are
descendants of St Lucy and that valoc is
hunting them down in search of the eyes
a sacred Relic in Lucy's family that
holds spiritual power much like the
blood of Christ according to his records
he thinks they can find the eyes buried
at the monastery of Jean Paul rodar
which is now a boarding school they rush
over there hoping to arrive before The
Relic falls into the wrong hands and the
first person she encounters is none
other than her old guide Frenchie but
the reunion is soured by IR 's
accusation that the evil is living
inside of him get away from them what we
need to go now it's you it's inside of
you this causes the dormant unholiness
to take over his body and deliver a
chilling greeting hello sister when she
tries to follow him he right hooks her
into a window but she comes back with
the rosary and demands the demon to
leave his body sister Deborah chips in
with the Bellinger bash and they chain
up the unconscious Maurice in the
hallway he's sick we're going to help
him but we need your help Sister Irene
has some serious Universal Studios ride
pre-show energy right here like how they
always try to make the rider feel like
they're a part of the story and then the
help that we give is literally just
being along for the ride but then when
you get back to the station everybody
claps for you like you've accomplished
something they realize that Frenchie was
headed towards the old haunted chapel
and the young boarding student Sophie
fills them in on the lore that the goat
on the stained glass window is a devil
whose eyes will glow red when the Sun
hits it at the right angle they're able
to recreate this with the flashlight and
find the end point of the red beam which
must be pointing out where the eyes of
St Lucy or Barry if you're getting a
little bit of deja vu it's probably
because this is the exact same puzzle as
the one that Irene solved back to The
Abbey of St Carta to find the blood of
Christ but this time instead of being
directed by a supposedly Divine figure
she's following the clues of a
supposedly demonic one is this
representative of the potential danger
that lies in trying to use the eyes a
sign that this time they're playing with
a weapon that they may not be able to
control maybe the goat demon disappears
from the stained glass and appears in
the girl sleeping quarters on the other
side of the school causing Mayhem for
them to tend to but they soon discover
the reason this previously inanimate
object has come to life Frenchie has
escaped from his chains under Val's
control and he arrogates Sophie's mom
out of the way on route to tackling
Sister Irene and forcing a fumble which
is recovered and advanced by Sophie this
does draw Frenchie Val's attention away
but Sister Irene is left in pretty bad
shape there may be some symbolism here
pertaining to Irene's own relationship
with her father there's no mention of
him being physically abusive towards her
but Irene says that she was sent Away by
him because that was easier than trying
to understand her clearly it's a strange
Rel relationship Frenchie has been
trying to take on a fatherly role
himself lately doing his best to serve
as a role model for Sophie before Sister
Irene showed up so his attack on Sister
Irene was likely received as a very
personal jab given her problems with her
own father it wouldn't be that different
from when Valic temporarily possessed
Sister Irene in 1952 and started hurling
targeted insults about Frenchie being
The Village Idiot the extremely helpful
archive librarian guy even hinted that
the demon of St cardo would choose a
form to prey on her fears and the fears
of those around you you must be prepared
to stop it at all costs that guy was
such a king by the way he basically
solved the whole mystery for them told
them exactly where to go and what they
would be up against and his name isn't
even mentioned outside of the credits
let's give it up for father Ridley the
true hero of the story anyway Irene is
only able to track down where Sophie and
Frenchie Valic ran off to after seeing
this Tower start to crumble under the
power of St Lucy's eyes which she uses
to ward off the demon moments before
retrieving the Blessed artifact from
Sophie her will is tested when Frenchie
what appears to be the real Frenchie it
gets through and begs for his life s
please it's K me but she knows she must
not hold back in order to prevent anyone
else from becoming a victim plus that's
what father Ridley told her and he's
basically a God among men at this point
just when it seems he's finished
Frenchie Valic Springs back to life and
grabs the eyes from her and seems to
absorb them and Valic Rises up in none
form behind him now taking on an
enormous stature she tries using the
rosary but that didn't work in 1952 so
why would it work now Valic responds by
shooting the chain at sister Deborah and
Irene is levitated into the air in a
crucifixion pose and lit on fire Valic
seems to be using the power of the eyes
to deal Irene with the same fate that St
Lucy once suffered but then Irene
experiences a quick flash of images so
let's break them down first she hears
her mother's words I will always be with
you then she sees her mother looking at
her followed by two images of the
burning St Lucy at the hands of the
pagans then the picture of St Lucy from
father nor re's Church she also sees
valik standing in Lorraine Warren's home
in 1977 and intercut with more flashes
of her mom an image of Lorraine Warren
opening her eyes after seeing valac for
the first time which also doesn't happen
until 1977 not the first example of her
having future sight but maybe the first
time that she gets a glance into someone
else's future after a few more images of
the attempted burning of St Lucy her own
flame goes out and she falls to the
ground like St Lucy the Pagan was unable
to burn her and I'm considering Bak who
represent the Pagan in this instance
because Valex lore comes from a grimoire
or spell book called ARS gotia part of a
series of demon summoning guide books
called the Lesser key of Solomon so the
summoning of valik is not connected to
any major religion thus making it a
pagan mythological entity so what do all
of these images me well remember back at
the beginning when I suggested that
Irene and Lorraine probably have some
blood relation due to the actresses that
portray them Vera and tysa figa being
sisters well there's another pair of
characters whose actresses share common
blood St Lucy and Irene's Mom are both
played by case colbrook which to me
suggests that these characters are
supposed to be related as well meaning
that Irene and lorine are both part of
the bloodline of St Lucy which means
that the images that flash through
Irene's head have one thing in common
they're all blood relatives when Irene's
mom says I will always be with you she's
not just talking about her memory she's
referring to the supernatural power of
the St Lucy bloodline the power that
when combined with the eyes of St Lucy
seems to protect her from the threat of
burn ination through the fire in the
Flames Sister Irene carries on it's
further suggested shortly after when
Irene recalls father Ridley's quip about
the Lucy family when Lucy was was
murdered her family escaped they were
hunted scattered across the globe
perhaps the eyes of St Lucy are not only
an artifact but also a generational gift
allowing those in her bloodline to have
psychic Visions it would certainly seem
plausible because Lorraine has the same
gift and in The Conjuring to and
Annabelle comes home it's clear that
she's passed it down to her daughter
Judy Warren mom who's
that but the battle isn't over yet
sister Deborah joins Sister Irene in
prayer and in probably the most fren
thing that could have possibly happened
barrels of red wine burst open and
washed Valic away causing the infernal
enemy to somehow dry up and combust into
an epic Inferno Frenchie is temporarily
able to regain control of his body but
the evil would continue to lie dormant
inside of him but for the time being it
seemed that Sister Irene had paid back a
favor by Saving his life four years
after he had done the same for her the
two would see each other off for
presumably the final time this time with
just a nod as Frenchie moves on with his
new found family
yeah and that's just it sister Irene's
story arc is not a typical final girl
archetype of a girl coming out of her
shell to kill the villain or overcoming
her fear to escape her stalker in true
Conjuring fashion it's more of a
spiritual journey she's been chosen by a
higher power whether that be God or
Cardinal bad news Conroy and she's
forced to demonstrate her faith by
taking her vows and believing in her
Visions my problem is that her entire
character Arc is completed in the nun
one and character-wise nothing really
happens with her in the nun two you
could say that I was none too pleased
with the sequel the extremely helpful
librarian father Ridley does more than
she does in that movie he literally does
all the work for her he solves the
mystery of the Lucy family crest for her
he explains all the lore to them then
when she wants to find the eyes he's
like I already found them and tells her
exactly where to go it's so bizarre
Irene is basically only relevant in the
nonto because she was born with St
Lucy's blood it's not something that she
earned or struggled for so it feels
cheap when that ends up being what helps
her overcome valent this is what I call
a chosen one story there are two types
of Chosen One Stories the good kind and
the bad kind in the good kind the hero
is destined to become the only one who
can defeat the villain but Success is
Not Guaranteed for example in Harry
Potter which also takes place in a
European boarding school a prophecy
seems to point to Harry being the only
one with the power to defeat the Dark
Lord but he still has to mature and form
relationships and overcome adversity by
embracing The Power of Love along the
way his character Arc ultimately puts
him in a position where he could be the
Victor The Legend of Zelda Twilight
Princess has a protagonist referred to
as the hero chosen by the gods but that
doesn't make him immune to death he has
to build trust with his companion midna
and learn ancient skills along the way
in order to even have a chance Sister
Irene seems to just be Invincible
against fire because she was born that
way she didn't really earn it she's more
like Rey from the Star Wars sequel
Trilogy she's essentially able to win
very early on because of who she is
again this is more of a problem with the
second non movie than the first if you
want to see an example of how this could
have been done a little better watch
Insidious the last key in that movie
Elise Rainer is a psychic ghost and
Demon Hunter just like Sister Irene who
had almost the exact same problem with
her dad not believing or being afraid of
her psychic abilities and treating her
poorly because of it Elise lives her
life hunting some of the world's
scariest demons but none of that
compares to her personal demons with her
father in the end the antagonist keyface
uses her father's ghost to confront her
and she must overcome the familial
issues in order to hunt down her Real
Enemy Valic has the ability to take on
any form which is why it chooses the
nonform to mock the sisters at the Abbey
of St CA in nonan one so it would have
made sense for one of the alternate
forms to resemble sister Irene's
personal demon in her relationship with
her father in the second movie you know
instead of this random goat from the
stained glass window if you want to see
my full analysis of keyface by the way
that link will be in the description but
to get a proper grasp on how everything
connects in The Conjuring Universe
you'll want to have your pointer possess
that playlist on the left remember to
subscribe to C's world for new Horrors
every week ring the death bell for all
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we both
survive
[Music]